you're watching Al Jazeera a reminder of
our top stories this hour
the Kremlin says it's halted its
participation in the Black Sea grain
deal Moscow says it's conditions for
extending the deal had not been
fulfilled it was due to expire later on
Monday evening
all right well let's look into the story
a bit more because there's some green
deals hugely vital not only for those in
the region but for many around the world
who dependent upon Ukraine one of the
biggest grain producers in the world
let's speak now to Rob McBride uh for
more on this and and Rob as I was saying
there the Kremlin indicating that it
would not throw its weight behind this
all-important deal tell us more
yeah that's right there has been some
speculation about whether the cranlin
would renew this deal it has been
reluctant to it only gave a 60-day
renewal which expires today Monday
instead of the usual uh four months a
renewal period that it was meant to give
and it has just announced in the last
half hour or so that from today Monday
this deal will cease to cease to exist
it is said that it will return to the
deal once conditions affecting Russia
are fulfilled and we don't know quite
what they mean by that but it is known
that Russia has been pushing in return
for renewing this deal some kind of
sanctions relief on the sanctions
imposed on it in return there's been
talk about uh possibly allowing one of
its uh Banks to have access to the
international money transfer system the
so-called Swift system
um but so there have been negotiations
going on behind the scenes they say that
this is not connected at all to the
attack on the Kirch bridge that Vladimir
Putin the Russian president has already
outlined um these uh the problems with
the deal beforehand but that is the
latest news they said that this deal
will not now be renewed and Rob what do
we imagine the likely reaction from the
ukrainians will be around this decision
yes I think everybody accepts that this
deal has been extremely important in
getting millions of tons of Ukrainian
food out to World Markets remember this
time last year we were in a pretty a
Dire Straits we were talking about price
hikes of around 30 percent in the cost
of food grain on the world markets the
impact of that on famine in different
parts of Africa and so on since then the
the food prices have come down somewhat
the food inflation we know is still a
problem but Farmers here in Ukraine have
found other ways of getting their grain
their harvests out to World Markets
using land borders using ports on the
Danube River instead of going across the
uh the the Black Sea which needs Russian
permission and also the number of ships
that have been allowed under this grain
deal
um have fallen dramatically up to only
in some respects a couple of ships a day
the Russians have been accused by the
ukrainians of dragging out the
inspections on these ships and really be
restricting the number so a lot of
farmers here in Ukraine have found
different ways of getting their food out
to world markets and I think a lot of
the farmers we've been talking to in the
southern part of Ukraine are also
concerned about the Russians putting on
unacceptable conditions for them
renewing this deal so there is I think a
mixed reaction here in Ukraine
all right Rob many thanks for that Rob
McBride on that to breaking news that
Russia has decided it will not throw its
weight and support behind renewing that
all-important grain deal from Ukraine
thanks Rob